each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so the theme for this lecture is
that privacy loss is a random variable
so this is our definition of the privacy
loss the log of the ratios so it's a
random variable what does epsilon 0
differential privacy guarantee it
promises that this random variable is
bounded by epsilon now sometimes the
privacy loss could be negative at least
intuitively so for example 14 mulling
this can happen because this log might
be negative maybe the numerator is
smaller than the denominator so suppose
for example that the adversary knows
that we are in one of the following two
cases either the number of people in the
database satisfying property P is K
which is the grape which then gives the
gray probability distribution when we
add Laplace noise or the number is k
plus 1 which gives us the red
probability distribution so suppose the
true answer is k plus 1 then outputs
that are more likely under the grey
distribution than they are under the red
distribution will give us a kind of
negative privacy loss it says that the
coin flip is kind of helping even a
little bit extra to hide that person's
presence okay so I want to exploit the
fact that that this is a random variable
and sometimes it can be negative it's a
bounded random variable and sometimes it
can be negative so let's review the
definition of the KL divergence the
called Black Label diverge
it's not symmetric so KL here y and z
are two different probability
distributions all right and the way I've
written this part of the slides I'm
assuming that the probability space is
discrete everything is more or less the
same with continuous but it's just
easier to write it this way so suppose
for example that why is the distribution
on outputs of our epsilon zero
differentially private mechanism when
the database is X and Z is the
distribution when the database is a
neighboring X prime so de KL divergence
is just this expectation of the log of
these probabilities so it's the worst
case over all adjacent X Prime in the
worst case over all adjacent X prime the
KL divergence will be a bound on the
expected loss of the algorithm right
because that's what that's what we're
summing in here something's bothering me
I'm missing a term right I need to turn
their the probability that Y is equal to
y 0 is in the expectation right okay
fine great ok so it's by this is by
definition an average notion and so that
means that bounded KL divergence does
not necessarily ensure differential
privacy and the literature contains
other average notions of privacy loss so
it's for example definitions based on
mutual information and whenever you see
somebody give you a definition that's an
average case notion you should check you
should say what happens to an outlier is
the outlier protected a lot of times
these average case notions specifically
fail when you've got some weirdo in the
database and the problem is that it's
the weirdo who particularly needs to
detection so it's just something to keep
in mind all right we define a worst-case
notion of the divergence which we call
the maximum divergence and that's just
the maximum over all of the events s in
the support of Y of this ratio of
probabilities okay so this is a
worst-case notion and a randomized
algorithm is epsilon zero differentially
private if and only if for every pair of
adjacent databases the max divergence is
bounded by epsilon okay it's just an
equivalent definition
so what we want to prove now is that the
expected privacy laws so privacy losses
are random variable we want to prove
that the expected profit privacy loss is
going to be something like epsilon
squared if the worst-case privacy loss
is Epsilon so in other words if you have
an epsilon zero differentially private
mechanism then the expected privacy loss
of this mechanism is going to be bounded
by two epsilon squared so let's just go
through the proof first of all by
definition the KL divergence is this
quantity it's the probability under
distribution d of seeing q times the log
of this ratio summed over all q and from
the log some inequality we know that
this is at least 0 it's non-negative so
that means that the KL divergence of D
with D prime is at most the sum of the
KL divergence of itself plus some term
which is at least 0 all right so now
we're just pulling off from the
definition simply are summing both of
these terms now over all Q so it's a
straight expansion in this step what do
we do
we subtracted off a d of q times the log
of d prime of Q over d of kill okay and
we also added it back in so we didn't
make any change all right but of course
this is just zero so this term goes away
and we're bounding d prime of Q minus D
of Q by the absolute value of D prime of
Q minus D of Q and we're bounding this
thing by epsilon because it's an epsilon
differentially private mechanism okay
alright so going back to this absolute
value we're bounding that you're sort of
plug in this is at most the maximum
minus the minimum of those two terms
okay so then we use the fact that this
max is at most e to the epsilon times of
men because it's an epsilon
differentially private mechanism uh then
what do we do oh yeah we regrouped our
terms that's all and then finally we use
the fact that this is a probability
distribution so this thing summed over
all Q will be at most one and that gives
us our belt okay so this is going to be
really powerful because we're gonna be
able to start doing stuff by saying well
what do we really expect is going to
happen oh really we expect the
expectation loss not this worst-case
loss so this is just a recapitulation of
what we said before now this measure is
kind of brittle in the sense that if we
make a small change in the probability
space we could make a really really big
difference in this measure so for
example I could take for some event s if
Susie doesn't have a whole lot of
probability for that event could like
modify Z and and and and make it down to
zero it's a small change in the
probability distribution but now I'll
have a zero in the denominator so it is
it's very fragile and it makes sense to
relax it a little bit and we do this we
call it Delta approximate max divergence
and basically what we're saying is this
condition that we want
and so much to hold that the ratio would
be bounded by eating the epsilon well we
want that to hold almost everywhere
except will give up on it in some little
region of size Delta so formally that's
what we have here we bound that we
define this to be the maximum over all s
and the support of why but only require
it for these events s where the
probability under why is at least Delta
the probability under y is less than
Delta that we just have no condition no
requirement yes I'm sorry
how is this a worst-case notion uh why
do you think it isn't
if they're if they're very divergent
then this simply won't hold there will
be more than some Delta region of the
space in which this ratio fails
how does it fail it so if there's a
region of the space so think of an event
that can happen under the distribution
when the database is X but it cannot
happen when the district when the
distribution is X prime if that event
has it has a big probability a
probability bigger than Delta under X
then that event s would be one of this
type the probability is is bigger than
Delta under X but this logarithm n know
this logarithm we'd have a zero in the
denominator we'd have a nonzero thing
here but a zero in the denominator so it
would fail so another way of saying this
is what I have here at the top of the
slide we define epsilon delta
differential privacy we said the
mechanism gives epsilon delta
differential privacy if for all pairs of
adjacent databases this condition holds
that the probability of an event under x
is bounded by e to the epsilon times the
probability under X prime plus this
Delta term and when you shift these
things around you see that you get
exactly this expression you subtract the
Delta over here and then divide through
by that probability and you get this so
this Delta approximate max divergence is
another way of saying different epsilon
delta differential privacy and this
epsilon delta notion comes up a lot and
we'll see a couple of reasons why and
the notion of differential privacy that
we've been talking about until now
simply has Delta set to 0 and that's why
I kept dragging around that epsilon zero
no
notation okay so here are some yes
right so I'm not sure I understood you
but it says that with probability 1
minus Delta the ratio will hold that
Delta is the mass where the guarantee
could fail that's right and if it fails
it can fail spectacularly the definition
permits it to fail really spectacularly
in the case that the bound epsilon is
not observed it could be infinite even
in that in that region so here are some
things to think about um first of all
think about like it's kind of an order
of quantifiers so this says fix X and X
Prime once they are fixed the
probabilities with probability 1 minus
Delta the privacy loss will be bounded
by epsilon and again the probability
space is the coin flips of our mechanism
this is a little bit different than with
epsilon zero differential privacy which
says fix X and now for all X Prime
simultaneously the privacy loss will be
bounded by epsilon so it's definitely a
weaker a promise I should note here that
although the definition doesn't say so
in the literature we we take Delta
typically to be what we call
cryptographically small that is its some
function that grows more slowly than one
over any polynomial in the size of the
database so it you should think of it as
something that should be extremely rare
you wouldn't expect it to happen just
like when you use a public key
cryptosystem you don't expect the
adversary to guess the
Shin King it's just very rare yes
definitely weaker
you'll see I want to just talk a little
bit more about ways in which its weak
and what it isn't doing and then I'll
tell you what it does do okay so here
are two possible worlds Cynthia is in
the database the database is X and here
are various properties Cynthia has does
not have property p1 she has property p2
and p3 but not p 4 and so on so that's
what happens under X now consider some
alternate reality in which maybe she has
properties 1 through 4 but not 5 through
it 8 now suppose we run so this is
reality this is an alternate reality but
this is the real reality suppose we run
a a set of counting queries and we add
noise we're not going to add enough
noise the noise won't be the great noise
that we've been using for epsilon zero
differential privacy somehow it won't be
good enough for that all right but it'll
be symmetric now suppose that the noise
has the following property it's positive
when we do the releases for the first
four queries and it's negative when we
do the releases for the next four
queries ok so in other words the noise
agrees with the alternate reality so if
we chose the alternate reality after the
fact we could make the sequence of
outcomes that are seen much more likely
than then they would be under the true
database x and that's why it's so
important that we fix X prime in advance
to make sense out of this so what I'm
saying is if I am in the database and
you do ask these
there is some alternate need that is
somehow or other a much more likely
explanation of this data than what you
saw there are much more likely
explanation of the data that you saw
than the truth but it's not very
meaningful but in any case this is to
try to illustrate the difference between
epsilon Delta and epsilon zero you just
won't have this with epsilon delta with
epsilon zero differential privacy and
we're noise will be such that will
guarantee that it doesn't happen so the
semantics are a little bit this very big
difference that I just Illustrated is a
complexity that arises when the data
rows are very complicated like there was
a whole lot of information about me and
I had some properties and I didn't have
other properties and all kinds of
combinations were possible if my data in
the database were simply a single bit
then there would be very little
difference here there's only one
alternate world with respect to me it's
just the fact that there are many
alternate worlds with respect to me that
makes this different that accentuates
this difference okay um so to answer
your question why do we care why do we
do it because it's a week or privacy
guarantee so it turns out that there are
a lot of things that you might want to
do algorithmically that this is really
helpful with I'll give you three
examples so the first one we call sorry
proposed test and release before I
explain this
I should say something that you might
have been wondering and I think somebody
might even have asked on the first day
and today is the day to talk about it we
have a database we have a function that
we want to compute on this database on
this particular database there is no
neighbor no immediate neighbor that
gives a very different outcome there
exists pairs of neighboring databases
for which the sensitivity is high but
this database is not an element in such
a pair so what we really would love to
be able to do is to somehow add noise
that sort of just covers the distance
between this database and its neighbors
and not between the worst-case pair of
adjacent databases now so let's call
that kind of more local notion in the
literature it's called local sensitivity
I prefer the term instance sensitivity
and here's an exercise it's not safe to
add noise that is simply scaled you know
laplacian noise that's scaled to the
instance sensitivity so if you have any
idea why give that some thought I'm
sorry
you're going in the right direction it's
not an exact answer but you're in the
right direction try to think about a
concrete example where you where I don't
want to say it just think about a little
but you're definitely in the right
direction so one approach to dealing
with this is called smooth sensitivity
this was an approach proposed by um and
you seem Roscoe de Nicola and Smith and
and I'm wondering if I actually wrote
something about this yes so what they
say is somehow you add noise in a very
smooth envelope around the instant
sensitivity and I should just explain my
picture I'm sorry I didn't do that so
here we have two neighboring databases
whose image under F are very close here
we have some other neighboring databases
whose image under F is very different
and the goal is that we won when we can
we want to add noise that's more scaled
like this that's what this picture is
about so this um so there is this
framework called the smooth sensitivity
framework and it's very elegant and it's
also a little bit hard to work with so
there are other there's another approach
which we call proposed test and release
which basically is a quick and dirty
alternative to the elegant and beautiful
work of museum Raskolnikov and Smith and
the idea is this you want to come up
with a differentially private test to
see whether the local sensitivity the
instant sensitivity this instance is
small so it has to be a
privacy-preserving test of insensitivity
and then if the algorithm says yes yes
the local sensitivity the instant
sensitivity is small you you can then
take the next step and add small noise
and if it says oh I can't promise you
that the instant sensitivity is small
then the algorithm says alright I'm
going to use maybe the technique of me
seemed Rusko didn't come on Smith or
I'll do something else or maybe I'll
quit why would quitting at this point be
a good idea let's think of an example
where it's exactly the right thing to do
you have a database drawn from some
population and you're trying to find the
median for this for these for the values
in your database now if your
distribution is very bimodal you might
have a whole bunch of people over here
and a whole bunch of people over here
and kind of nothing here at the median
all right is the median interesting in
this case is it a meaningful statistic
no it's not meaningful you really here
have two populations and you want the
medians of each of them so in some sense
if you're looking at the median it might
be perfectly reasonable to say no I
don't like this situation this is the
wrong kind of data set for a median
obviously the underlying distribution
has no mass at the median forget it on
the other hand it turns out this is the
only problem as long as there's positive
density at the median you're the median
does make sense so what you can do is
using this PTR example technique is to
say is the current instance so let's say
that our numbers are between are between
0 and 1 everybody's value is between 0
and 1 um
and you could say is the current
instance far from one with let's say
sensitivity of 1 over n the cubed root
of N and this question is the current
instance far from or how far is the
current instance from a different
instance where the sensitivity is less
than 1 over cube root of n that's just a
sensitivity one query how many people do
I have to change in order to get myself
from this instance to one that's
sensitive how many people do I have to
change that's a counting query okay so
you can use Laplace noise for that right
well sometimes and then if the answer
comes back that says oh you're really
far you're like log squared and away
from such a thing then you can say great
i'm going to use noise that's scale to 1
over cubed root of n now why is this
whole thing not actually epsilon zero
differentially private why is this
algorithm not epsilon zero
differentially private
well when I asked that counting query
how far am i from a database that is
sensitive there's a Laplace that's added
to the answer maybe my database is
really sensitive but for some you know
terrible reason the Laplace happened to
give a big value when I sampled from the
Laplace I got log squared in or you know
log squared n over epsilon so I kind of
got a false reading of insensitive it's
very unlikely but it could happen this
is one case where we would love to relax
to epsilon Delta differential privacy
something could go wrong but it's really
unlikely
that's a one example here's another one
so we're gonna prove a really powerful
theorem really powerful theorem and in
fact you've actually seen almost the
entire proof already this morning we
call it the advanced composition theorem
and it has a qualitative and
quantitative aspect so qualitatively so
far when we've been talking about
composition most of the time we're
talking we've been conceptually thinking
about many queries to the same database
but I did mention early on the first day
that you actually get composition for
free over completely non communicating
separated databases if I have one
database over here with Ravi condoms
data in it and it's epsilon 1
differentially private and another one
over here I said with Ravi's data in it
that's epsilon 2 differentially private
then the universe as a whole is still at
least them at worst epsilon 1 plus
epsilon 2 differentially private so we
want to sort of really capture the sense
in which things are working over
multiple databases so we're going to
look at a situation where the adversary
can repeatedly create databases even and
choose which mechanisms are going to run
on them and still cumulatively it won't
get a whole lot of information and when
we do that we can start answering
questions of the following form consider
Bob who goes through life and over the
course of his lifetime takes part in say
10,000 epsilon prime 0 differentially
private databases and suppose I want his
lifetime cumulative
salon loss to be one what should I
choose epsilon prime to be that's the
kind of question we're going to be able
to answer when we prove this theorem
quantitatively the theorem says the
following first let's think about it
setting Delta 20 when we do that it says
if we have K epsilon zero differentially
private mechanisms then for every delta
prime their composition which we will
define when i tell you how we're going
to that was the qualitative part how do
we model composition their composition
will be at worst 2 K log of 1 over delta
prime times epsilon plus something
bounded by K times epsilon squared Delta
0 plus delta prime 0 comma delta prime
differentially private so we're getting
something that looks a lot like square
root of K times epsilon plus this term
comma delta prime differential privacy
not blah blah blah zero differential
privacy only this relaxed notion now
when when we allow when we look at
composition of epsilon Delta
differential mechanisms when Delta is
not 0 those deltas show up here now
remember they're supposed to be
cryptographically tiny and K is
something that actually happens in a
lifetime so K times Delta is also going
to be really really tiny and actually
looking at delta prime but or you know
something like that so the key point
here is that the thing that's
multiplying epsilon looks more like
square root of K than it does k
yes it has this log of 1 over delta
prime term but it has only a square root
of K if we choose now over here we have
K times epsilon squared something that's
at most K times epsilon squared so if we
choose epsilon prime to be epsilon
divided by square root of K then this
term and this term start looking like
they're in approximately the same
ballpark and we were ending up with
something that is more or whose
dependence on K is square root of some
constant times K okay so that's where
we're that's what we're aiming at so
here's how we modeled capable adaptive k
fold composition we think about it as a
game between the adversary and the
universe the universe has various
database sorry yeah no no the adversary
in the universe the very first thing the
universe is going to do its is going to
flip a coin and choose 0 or 1 with equal
probability it does not tell the
adversary the outcome of that choice it
knows it now the adversary produces a
pair of adjacent databases x1 0 and X 11
the first subscript 1 says that this is
the first round and it has a 0 1 in the
first round and 11 in the first round it
also presents to the universe a
differentially private mechanism m1 the
universe according to the according to
the choice of be that was fixed in
advance and that the adversary doesn't
know takes this mechanism uses be too
elect among these two applies the
mechanism to the selected one and gives
the response that's the first round
depending on what it has seen the
adversary chooses a new pair of adjacent
databases x 20 and it's 21 and a new
mechanism and gives this to the universe
and the universe using that same be that
fixed in advance selects from this pair
applies the mechanism and response and
we iterate k times that's k fold
adaptive adaptive because the adversary
is adapting its choices of databases and
mechanisms composition alright the
adversaries goal in life is to guess
that secret bit big that's all
what the B does not change he could
guess he could do that and then he would
have no advantage I mean he would just
have a 50-50 chance the adversary wins
if he kind of substantially beats a
fifty-fifty chance so one way to think
about this so first of all we gave the
adversary a lot of power here that's
just for show that has it plays
absolutely no role it turns out um the
only thing that's really going to matter
is that we have independent the random
variables in each step in this direction
are chosen independently of each other
that's the only thing we're actually
interested in but one of the things that
this you know if you simplify it it
could model that maybe B equals 0 is the
real world and B equals one might be the
world in which Bob's data in every
single database that he participates in
is replaced with junk or deleted okay
and we're trying to say that the
adversary can't tell the difference
between the real world and this junk
world
so the proof of the composition theorem
as I said you've essentially seen the
whole proof already let's look at the
epsilon zero case so our mechanisms m1
m2 that the adversary chose on the
previous picture they're all epsilon
zero differentially private so what do
we know each one is epsilon zero
differentially private so for each one
the expected privacy loss is bounded by
2 epsilon squared that was the lemma
that we proved earlier so we model the
cumulative privacy loss as a martingale
we have a bound on the maximum loss
that's Epsilon we got that from the fact
that it's an epsilon zero differentially
private mechanism we have a bound on the
expectation we got that from our lemma 2
epsilon squared and now we applied the
azuma hosting bounds which says what
that the probability that our cumulative
loss the sum over our privacy losses of
all of the m is all of those mechanisms
minus k times this bound you can kind of
think about that as well n minus K times
is bound the probability of this
quantity in absolute value exceeds any Z
times the square root of K times the
expectation is exponentially small and Z
squared over 2
and this is essentially what the same
kind of theorem that sanjeev was
referring to yesterday this this is
these are turn off bounds and the only
thing that we really need here again is
that the privacy law setting stuff is
independent bounded random variables ok
so my fabulous animation there's my
privacy loss so you know it's a random
walk and go sometimes to the right
sometimes to the left but it doesn't
ultimately drift all that far from its
expectation how about the epsilon delta
case instead of epsilon zero so there
ought to be a way using some general as
a proving it using some generalization
of these bounds um the way we did it in
the paper was um ah i'm sorry i forgot a
word uses what's something called the
dense model theorem for distributions
and basically what it says is if these
things have Delta approximate max
divergence from each other then in
particular there is a y prime which has
max divergence epsilon and that is
statistically close to Y Prime and we
use this thing k different times and
that's where we end up with our k
Delta's in our bound and
we would have to go through a lot to
prove it and we don't need to okay so
here's something to think about we've
pictured in the upper right our little
interactive game that we have in k fold
adaptive composition and we said that it
sort of hides the presence of Bob's data
or my data so I'm in various databases
and this thing hides my presence or
absence or hides the value of my data
what it is not doing is hiding
simultaneously my absences in all of the
databases that I don't participate in
right so in some sense it's a little bit
like the kind of phenomenon that we had
with epsilon and Delta says fix to
alternate realities you're not going to
be able to distinguish between them
we're going to come back to something of
this form either on the last lecture or
in a problem session that day but I mean
this really is food for thought think
about what does it mean I don't really
know what it means I have you know some
days I think I get it in some days I
know I don't understand it but of course
I can't be everywhere that's humanly
impossible so does it think about it I
don't have conclusions to tell you about
this okay a third relaxation the third
um use of epsilon delta differential
privacy the addition of gaussian noise
rather than laplace noise
so we've seen the first theorem before
Delta one here f could be a function
that map's x2 some point in
high-dimensional space d dimensional
space we defined the l1 sensitivity
delta which we were calling it before
but now i'm going to emphasize that this
is the this is the l1 sensitivity as the
maximum over X and X prime of the l1
norm of f of X minus f of X prime we can
also define Delta 2 to be the l2
difference between them right whereas
when we're using Laplace noise Delta 1
over epsilon yes Delta 1 over epsilon in
every component in order to get epsilon
differential privacy we're going to add
noise using somehow defined by Delta 2
but it's going to be normally
distributed with zero mean in order to
get epsilon delta differential privacy
and this theorem says that it's
sufficient for the variance to be Delta
2 over epsilon 2 quantity squared
remember that the standard deviation is
going to be the square root of that it
will be our normal what we're used to
Delta over epsilon term only now it's
Delta two rather than Delta 1 and then
it will have something that depends
logarithmically at one over Delta
ok now let's prove this theorem because
everybody refers to it and to my
knowledge there's actually no proof in
the literature oh before i prove it i
just want to point out why is it again
why might it be a game well before we
had the composition theorem it would be
a game now that we have the compositions
here and we understand that we can get
similar bounds by composition of epsilon
zero but before we had that we didn't
know it we didn't know that you could
still use Laplace noise for that so it
seemed to be giving us that again
because let's say if you think about k
arbitrary sensitivity one queries like
counting queries the l1 sensitivity is k
and the l2 sensitivity is at most root k
so it seemed to be buying us a lot it
still buys us something in that well
actually okay privacy lost with Gaussian
noise good I want my privacy laws to be
bounded by epsilon my privacy loss is
the log of sort of the mass at X what
I'm sorry X here is a scalar it's not a
database I have two databases we're
looking at the one-dimensional case so
we're computing some function that's
real valued and the databases will
differ by the value of the function will
differ by at most Delta F in the
one-dimensional case the one norm is the
same as the two norm so I didn't bother
with the subscript okay so um so what I
need to
see when is the ratio of these densities
bounded by epsilon where the densities
look like e to the minus x squared over
2 Sigma squared in the numerator and in
the denominator the exponent has that
extra Delta F term right which gets
squared so taking logs we get this
taking logs and expanding out the X plus
Delta F squared and subtracting off we
end up with this expression right 1 over
2 sigma x two x delta f plus delta f
squared is bounded by epsilon in
absolute value is bounded by epsilon so
one way that this will definitely happen
if you sort of do this arithmetic throw
is when x in magnitude is bounded by
this this is just a reworking of that
it's gonna happen over here for exactly
the same reason but we're going to get a
little bit of extra mileage over here
because the situation isn't perfectly
symmetric but we do know for sure that
if this is the case then while X in
absolute value is bounded by that the
privacy loss will be bounded by epsilon
there will be other cases where it's
bounded by epsilon but it's at least in
those cases so to ensure epsilon Delta
differential privacy it's enough to
ensure that this condition will hold
sorry that this will fail with
probability at most Delta Delta all
right it will have a greater than rather
than a less than with probability at
most Delta now plug in absolutely
standard tailbones and just do the
arithmetic and it will end up showing
that it's sufficient for Sigma squared
to be
as large as Delta F over epsilon squared
to log of 2 over Delta just not nothing
magic there okay how about the high
dimensional case miraculously you heard
the proof of that yesterday sort of you
heard the key to the proof yesterday so
how are we going to go about the high
dimensional case in the high dimensional
case and this is the you know we're
adding a high dimensional Gaussian that
is we are sampling along each of these
different for each of these answers
we're doing another draw from the same
gaussian what did I hear some suggestion
so we could think of the total noise
vector that we're adding as a sample
from a symmetric spherically symmetric
Gaussian ok well let's set it up I took
what I had on the previous page slide
and i just put norms around everything
right so the privacy loss will be
bounded by epsilon whenever this holds
or equivalently when that holds all i
did was put norms around everything and
here the vector V is any vector whose
length whose Euclidean distance length
is at most Delta F because that's we're
now working with the l2 sensitivity so
we're going to use the fact that this
Gaussian but the spherically symmetric
that this noise that we've added which
we did by adding
dependent galleons in one dimension of
you know d times that that its spherical
symmetric so we could pretend that we
chose one of these orthonormal
components to be parallel to our sort of
error vector our noise vector V so let's
draw this but I'm going to do so again
are now choosing an orthonormal set of
basis vectors he's just a thought
experiment it's equivalent to what
actually happened so we've got this
orthonormal set d1 up to be m and b 1 is
parallel to v so our vector is the sum
over i equals 1 to N of lambda i bi
where this guy is parallel to fig and
lambda i was distributed as normal of 0
sinh squared um yeah signals burg okay
so we're looking for a bound on we
wanted to upper bound this difference so
here's my picture remember I've got an
orthonormal basis so I can slightly
decompose x2 it's part that's parallel
to V and everything else so this is X it
has a lambda 1 B 1 term and then the
other lambda I B is B 1 was chosen to be
parallel to thee so I can just line v up
over here and now this thing is simply x
+ V and now we know how to do this we
you know what is this term well it's the
sums of the squares of the lengths of
these guys this is some of the lambda
i's for I greater than 1 plus lambda 1
plus the length of V quantity squared
that's the square of X plus V right an x
squared is just the sum of the squares
of the lambda i's do the arithmetic you
end up with the length of V squared plus
2 times lambda 1 times the length of V
but we chose v.v is anything whose
length is bounded by Delta F so this
ends up being bounded by this this is
exactly the expression we had in the
one-dimensional case
hmm
yes
yes yes that's true that's another way
right okay so now you have two proofs
neither of which is in the literature
good all right um ok so now I want to
take a closer look at this i'm looking
here at cheating so instead of having
that log of 1 over delta term floating
around what happens if we drop it so
let's look at trying sigma equal to
Delta F over epsilon um it turns out in
that case you know doing the same
computations we did we're going to head
of our privacy laws bounded by epsilon
when this occurs and for exactly the
same reasons as before this will happen
when the absolute value of x is less
than sigma x 1 minus epsilon over
chillin right just to give you some idea
of some numbers and the motivation why
am i even thinking about dropping that
log of 1 over delta term if i don't drop
it what happens if i want to ask a
number of counting queries say 10 of
them and i'm going to take epsilon equal
to 1 and delta 0 then i get noise of 10
if i take epsilon equal to 1 and delta
uh sorry about that minus sign equal to
e to the minus 10 then i'm gonna end up
with noise about 20 bigger than 20 so
it's actually worse it only starts to
become good when K gets very big very
big
so that's no innovation so let's look at
this a little more carefully what
happens when X is outside of that range
did the world blow up did we fall off a
cliff no most likely what will happen is
that instead of having privacy loss of
Epsilon we're going to have a privacy
loss of two epsilon the Gaussian
degrades really nicely very gently so
really really bad things aren't going to
happen and or at least really bad things
will happen only with insanely small
probabilities so if you look in general
and at the probability that your privacy
loss is less than or equal to K epsilon
rather than just plain epsilon then you
end up with something that looks like
this so I have a k instead of a 1
alright and this probability is about 1
/ King eat ooh the minus K squared over
2 roughly by 10 you know standard tale
bounds so this looks pretty Gaussian
itself right looks like a normal
gaussian so in some intuitive sense the
privacy worst loss the behavior of this
privacy lost random variable is not
worse than that of a standard Gaussian
then you know it's kind of way you can
describe it bound it by a standard
Gaussian
and this suggests a current area of
research which is kind of a different
relaxation we had epsilon zero
differential privacy initially we
relaxed to epsilon delta differential
privacy but epsilon delta differential
privacy allows terrible things to happen
in the Delta region so it's very very
very good and then nothing is guaranteed
and here we're saying let's try a
different relaxation of epsilon zero
we're never gonna I mean you know the
the remoteness of the horrible is going
to be extremely small but we're gonna be
great gracefully and we call it we're
calling it concentrated differential
privacy so I'm not going to give you a
formal definition because it's not done
yet this is very very current question
but we did play with it on using these
gaussians and guy put it into Excel and
he came up with a nice drawing um first
of all this is what happens with the
cumulative distribution of the privacy
loss let's see if I get this right so in
epsilon zero there's no probability that
the privacy loss will be less than minus
1 there's no probability that the
privacy loss will be bigger than one and
uh what it does something or other in
here we don't know because we don't know
what the mechanism is there's no promise
all we know is that if not it lies in
this range right and um oh I guess we
know something about its expectation I
think here epsilon is one in these
examples okay with epsilon delta 0
there is some probability that you could
have big privacy loss
sorry
this is the probability yeah
and with concentrated differential
privacy sort of move smoothly in here
so we were thinking about this in the
context of the problem of you have a
medical database this is a real problem
you have a medical database they a
hospital database and your researcher
wants to know does the hospital database
contain enough people with certain
criteria satisfying certain criteria in
order to run a particular medical study
so the researcher actually has in mind a
specific study that they want to do and
they need so many you know 200 people
who have satisfy some set of conditions
and it turns out that in the United
States even to find out if the database
has enough people for you to try to
convince some set of them to join your
study you know big enough set of them to
join your study just to get permission
to find out if there's enough to even
bother trying you need to go through
what's called an IRB and institutional
review board so that's a time-consuming
difficult process so what if there were
a privacy-preserving way of simply
finding out is it worth your effort to
even try to go and recruit people for
this study from this hospital population
so if there were a privacy-preserving
way you could at least find out if it's
worth your effort without actually going
and getting this IRB approval so what
happens when in real life when they try
to do this I mean forget about the
privacy part suppose they have IRB
approval what happens in real life they
do some kind of
so they have approval they do some kind
of counting query and they're trying to
figure out are there enough for their
study they need 200 well they can't tell
for sure even if there were two hundred
twenty-five people in the database that
seemed to satisfy the conditions that
they want some of those people maybe
we'll say no I don't want to participate
in your study and it's their choice if
too many such people say they don't want
to participate in the study then the
study can't happen so you're counting
query even with no question of privacy
you're counting query can give you a
kind of false positive similarly it may
be that everybody who has this illness
or this condition is really willing to
participate in the study but you were
conservative and whereas you needed 200
you checked to see if there was 220
because you expected some people to say
no so if if the database in fact only
contained 205 and they were all willing
you'll still say oh no I'm not gonna
bother with this because you'll make
this error so you can have errors even
without privacy when you're trying to
guess whether it's worth trying to
recruit the patients you can have both
false positives and false negatives and
it's very interesting that if you look
at you know some of the things that
people in bioinformatics or the medical
informatics say they don't understand
that they themselves can get false
positives of this type so now what we're
going to do is we're going to use
privacy for the counting queries and and
we could see what happens with different
kinds of privacy conditions so one of
them would be this sort of using this
Gaussian thing where we just used Delta
F over epsilon or you could use epsilon
delta or you could do epsilon zero and
so you're gonna have errors either way
and this
what the probability distribution looks
like on your errors in the no privacy
case where you assume is kind of
Gaussian or concentrated case epsilon
Delta and epsilon zero so this is a sort
of motivator for continuing to pursue
these kinds of questions because you get
some error but so do the non private
people and you get less error than you
do with these other notions all right so
that's what I prepared it's a short
lecture but questions we covered a lot
of material
yes
what I swept so ah
as K increases the probability of having
a k epsilon privacy loss drops
exponentially and minus K squared over 2
so if a bad thing is having a k of 5 the
probability of that is is at most e to
the minus 12 and a half or something
like that so so that's the sense in
which we're saying that bad things
happen with very small probability as it
gets better and better the probability
of it happening is dropping really
really fast it's worth thinking about I
mean we haven't talked about what are
the semantics really of an epsilon
privacy loss and one of the reasons we
can't think that we haven't talked about
it is that we don't really understand it
um but given that we don't understand it
it didn't seem like a really bad idea to
push it farther in this particular way
Oh
that's true
yes
I'm sorry
oh can you write it can you write on the
board
I think that for now what we have to do
is we have to fix X and X prime because
we're into the epsilon delta world so we
have to fix X and X Prime in advance and
now we want to ensure that the it is
it's a maximum that way that we need to
affect to bound
okay so I think that you're right and I
think that I'm slopping so once you fix
X and X prime you can talk about the
privacy loss over X and X prime as you
run your you fix X s Prime now you run
your experiment on the database x that
defines a privacy laws with respect to X
Prime and that's what that's our random
variable now yes right so so that's the
difference between there was one of the
differences that I pointed out between
epsilon 0 and epsilon delta that you
like in that example I gave with me
having different properties if you chose
the properties afterwards you would
definitely fail here so you have to fix
okay
in the 1 minus epsilon delta case right
yes yes and that function I want to be
very concise didn't say this I want that
function to be tightly concentrated
around its mean just as in the indicates
that we were discussing here the this is
it this hat this is very tightly
concentrated well it's around them right
we have an expectation and we know that
we're not getting very big at all so
we're also not getting very far from our
expectation so I think that it will be
two bounded by a function that is a
tightly tightly concentrated function
like this Gaussian it would have mean
epsilon squared rather than 0 right I
think they said I did it's under
construction but it seems plausible
other questions that was a good question
other questions yes
Oh
great
um do you have in mind that you'll put
in some decoy records and maybe you'll
sample a record and release it and that
there will be some chance that it's a
decoy and therefore it's not
compromising anyone's privacy okay so
one possibility is you won't hit a decoy
when you sample you'll hit a non decoy a
real person and then in some adjacent
database that real person isn't there so
in that pair of adjacent databases the
probability that that real person is
harmed in your method in one of them is
something like 1 over the size of the
expanded database real database plus
decoys in the other one at 0 so with
probability 1 over they would say in the
bigger database the the expanded
database the privacy loss will be
infinite no so you have you have your
you have your real database and you've
added some decoys so this total thing
let's say has m rows in it in the
adjacent database this part okay
this guy is missing him is missing over
here this part is exactly the same and
you know maybe these guys these decoys
may be the same now over here the chance
that we violate this person's privacy if
you select a row at random is going to
be 1 over m here the probability that
you will hurt that person is zero so
this ratio is unbounded and this event
isn't so unlikely
they're not I'm telling you it doesn't
work to add decoys that having decoys in
the database doesn't necessarily protect
the privacy of somebody who's in the
database so okay so what I was analyzing
here was the mechanism where you choose
a random row and you publish it all
right now you are sort of right that if
the only thing that we're doing is
counting queries and we add decoys sort
of very random looking decoys then
that's like adding noise but it doesn't
have a lot of noise in expectation first
of all and if you ask several queries um
you'll start to detect the difference
between having somebody here and not
having him here that was kind of the
heart of the proof that I mentioned
yesterday where the adversary had in
mind two adjacent databases and there
was a gap of one and he asked a bunch of
random queries and that one guy kind of
asserted himself periodically right so
the same thing will happen here so it'll
protect you in some sense for a little
while but it won't protect you for very
very much
I don't know why you think they're
randomly distributed I don't know
anything about them all I know is that
they're there they aren't big do you
know whether they're randomly
distributed or not the Delta region the
the part of the probability space where
things are very different ah but that
doesn't nothing should you took the
words out of my mouth that's not random
we're ignorant but it's not random it
doesn't really work you know think about
some specific mechanisms and some
specific and start attacking them with
different sorts of queries and you'll
see that it doesn't decoys they work for
a little bit but they don't work a lot
other questions
you
ah well let's try to reconstruct that
the good thing whenever you're trying to
show something none that something is
not differentially private is that
differential privacy gives the adversary
a very unreasonable amount of
information he lets the adversary for
example choose a pair of databases that
differ only in one row and he knows
everywhere where they agree right so
somehow what you have to do in order to
do it to answer your question is you
have to find a pair of adjacent
databases where in one case the noise
would be big and in the neighbor it
would be small and then he asks a query
where he knows pretty much what the
answer is going to be and if the thing
he gets back is like a standard
deviation for the big noise then he says
oh it's really likely than in that case
so
right right exactly or again if he knows
the answer even just from one sample he
could say oh I wouldn't have gotten I
would be very unlikely do have gotten
that had we been in the neighboring
insensitive case this actually though I
mean you really have the feeling that
most things that people ought to want to
be learning from a statistical database
should be pretty insensitive and you
really do want to be able to take
advantage of that it's like what is a
statistical analysis if my presence or
absence in the database would completely
change the answer what does that mean it
about a statistic it's about Cynthia you
know doesn't make any sense and so it's
possible that for many things that you
want to do they'll be stable in a lot of
cases and this kind of quick testing
could work out well although then you
have to worry about the computational
complexity of the test and as you might
have noticed I haven't been talking
about computational issues yeah more
questions
okay good